so El Chapo is currently in prison
is he worth talking to
I'd say yes is there things that to you
are interesting about him they're still
not understood
is he a window into something that you
don't understand about that will still
are curious about in that world I think
he's a window into the family dynamics
of that world I want to say family
Dynamics uh Mexico has a big thing about
Compadres you know and Hermanos like we
have people that we call family that are
not necessarily our family
uh he is somebody that witnessed the the
the construction of what is now
the Sinaloa cartel like he was in it way
back when he started off as a
as a farmer and then went into
trafficking he's uh from a town called
mandirawata which is basically you know
that's the uh what kind of cartels
basically that's where a lot of that
originates
um
the the things that he saw as far as how
some of these things got built I think
would be an interesting uh topic of
conversation with somebody like him so
that story is the story of evolving
family Dynamics yeah part of the story
of the cartel is individual humans
marrying other families uh getting uh
getting named padrino basically
Godfathers to other people's kids
um forming family and Blood Ties and
influence ties to people not only in
Mexico but in the United States it's
seeing how that Dynamic and family
Dynamic is still there you know so he's
gone he's in prison but he is
he's probably on his way to be our next
uh clandestine Saint you go to the uh
the chapel of malberde
malberta is basically a Mexican Robin
Hood the folks ain't down there who is a
saint of traffickers
and at his shrine
you have small little chapel Shrine
right next to it so he's on his way to
sainthood in Mexico you know not not
recognized by the Catholic church but
that doesn't matter in Mexico anymore
speaking to somebody like him who
we can consider him somebody that lost
you know he's arrested but his family's
okay
his uh his legacy is out there he's
going to be named he's probably going to
be the next folk Saint when he passes
away do you think he feels like the new
wave of what the cartel has become is
betrayed him was left and behind or
um because it seems like the way the
cartel operated has changed over the
decades yeah well number one their power
and influence is bigger you know uh they
there are seen a lower cartel operations
in Colombia straight from straight to
the liking the source of it and uh then
there are clear uh they have a clear
presence in in places like Chicago and
Los Angeles uh they're in the United
States the whole thought process that a
lot of Americans have like oh we don't
want that trouble over here we don't
want them to get here or like build the
wall and all this so they're deeply
integrated into legitimate businesses I
mean they've been having kids and
families up here since for a long time
some of these people have passed
American passports that work not only
directly for them but have Blood Ties
down there you know there's been
dragnets and a rest of some of these uh
criminal organizations States uh New
Generation cartel had one two three
years ago where
the guest operation Anaconda I think it
was called they arrested over 80 of
their operatives and this is a new
cartel that is very militaristic and
growing in Mexico and they had over 80
arrests in the United States you know
that of members of them operating here